[Music]
michael tracy doesn't have a job in
mainstream journalism in a normal
country he would because his attitude is
the definition of what journalism is
supposed to be he's liberal in the
truest sense
he's skeptical he believes in free
speech he asks obvious questions
he notices obvious patterns and more
than anything he challenges people who
actually have power he punches up
not down and for that reason he's on sub
stack but we do pay very close attention
to him had on the show a couple of times
he's really smart and he notices things
the rest the media don't want you to
notice
this week he noticed something pretty
weird about the reaction to the jury
verdict in the derek chovan murder trial
it seemed like everybody in authority
was reading
almost like from the same script this
trial they told us in unison
isn't really over the fact is
we still have work to do the family does
not get to have their loved one back
there is still work to be done and while
this is a step in the right direction
there's still a lot of work to be done
but this is just one stop
there is more work to be done it's a
feeling like okay this happened
now the work really begins so we can't
leave this moment
or look away thinking our work is done
this moment
is where the work begins we've got a lot
of work to do but this feels like a
beginning
rather than a rather than an ending we
have a lot of work to do
in this country because systemic racism
has infected us all
and we know that until we stop the
violence
then we have work to do there's a lot of
work to be done
to get to liberty and justice
for all everyone
reading the bumper sticker the best is
the comedians
reading state approved propaganda so
many people have been so
gravely diminished by the past few years
but there's more more where that came
from
tracy then went and found a lot of other
people reading from exactly the same
script and it's an incredibly long list
if you want to understand the axis
between
politicians and big business and fake
state-approved comedians
just all of them everyone with power all
acting as one
in unison against you and your interests
basically telling you that yeah this guy
was found guilty of murder but you're
the one who's guilty
and we're gonna punish you we're going
to spend some time doing it that's
exactly what they're saying
then check this out best buy you thought
it was an electronic store
no quote best buy's unwavering
commitment to this work
is as strong as ever really what work i
thought you sold stereo speakers
best buy be quiet the san francisco
museum of modern art quite concerned too
we know there is still much work to be
done really what kind of work you be
doing
mr museum guy then the ceo of target
moved some words around quote
today's verdict does not mean that our
work is done there's much more to do
really getting the sense you're going to
be the subject
slash victim of this work yeah you are
it went on though
the ceo of starbucks nationwide and
american airlines all issued statements
declaring that more
work must be done so did hockey teams
and food delivery services
even politicians who have never even for
one day had a real job people like
bernie sanders
talked about the need to do more work
and by the way it wasn't just democrats
it was
let's say tim scott the senator from
south carolina republican the guy who'd
be giving the republican response on
wednesday night to the president's
speech to
joint session somehow managed to mirror
tim scott did the statement by yale
university's president
almost word for word quote we know there
is more work to be done
said tim scott yale statement read this
way we know there is
much more work to be done not more work
much more works the difference between
tim scott and the president of yale was
just one of degrees
tim scott said more the president said
much more that is kind of the difference
between the two parties isn't it
just a matter of degrees here's the
amazing thing
to restate none of these people explain
what all this work is
all that's clear is that you've got a
lot of work to do we'll have details for
you
coming soon hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else